The Joe Rogan Experience so how do you
get these bones how does this all start
get into that okay and uh
the way I discovered the bones is after
I bought the property
uh there was a
a stripping pile done by an adjacent
Miner
that was dumping overburden on this on
these flat tailings
and I had a tour guide
in a big guy
I said Josh run over there and find me a
mammoth tusk
I never found a mammoth tusk but I'd
heard they were finding them over there
and the groundwater dumping on was on my
ground
so he he went and he
he says what do they look like I said
well they look like tree trunks only
they got a curve to them
seeing went he was gone half an hour he
comes back with a seven foot Tusk over
his shoulder
holy [ __ ]
I said go get me another one he went and
came back an hour later with another one
about three feet long a broken one
so I walked over there
to look at this area where the mining
was going to take place
and they ended up mining it and they had
a right to mine it
The company took out about 3 000 ounces
out of this one little area
it's like God damn this stuff stinks so
one day
we were walking around the area after
they had mined it moved on to another
place
and we thought of the smell we walked
around the side of this hill
and we got up in this little draw
and we were picking my kids were with me
too we were picking bones off the off
the ground little shards little leg
bones and stuff
so we filled up a garbage bag with those
we went back again and again and again
and then I took an excavator back
built a little road around the side so
we get back to it with a machine
took a couple dirt digs out of the muck
found mammoth tusk
I said oh boy
let's get something going
so then we got a big floating barge and
put a pump on it 471 Jimmy
with a giant they're they're called
Giants but they're actually hydraulic
monitors they look like
big long pipes that you spray water out
of and our pump was a eight inch intake
six inch outtake and we nozzled it down
to two two inches two and a half inches
we could fire the water way out there
and wash the overburden away and the
overburden there is about 60 feet high
it's permafrost silt
and underneath that you have your gravel
layer underneath the gravel you have the
gold on the Bedrock
and the uh
gravel layer and the muck interface is
where most of the bones are
so we started finding lots of Bones I
mean a lot of Bones
and in the first three years we found
thousands and thousands of tusks and
bison heads and
bones and by the way you're
all those skulls you got out there
in your in your building here yeah you
ain't got to step by some skull
I'm gonna fix that [ __ ]
okay okay I'm gonna and then uh
I don't even know how many we have we
stopped counting and mammoth tusk same
thing and when did step Bisons go
extinct 12 000 years ago wow and so the
permafrost is slowly melting
and you're hosing it down and pulling it
so the stench is literally like this
ancient rotting biological material it
stinks
wow it's organic but it's been frozen
forever
thousands and twenty thousand years
thirty thousand years so this is uh you
with the hose spraying it onto the side
of this wall so the way you do it is you
just spray the side of these like what
would you call that Hill it's a muck
bench a muck bench yes sir so you spray
that until you see something poking
through yes sir well you spray it and
then you walk up there and you turn the
nozzle off the side and you'll pick up
the bones the little pieces leg bones
backbones why is there so much in this
one area nobody knows really nobody well
that's what's so crazy like when I
watched the documentary on your place
when you you show this giant room where
you have all these buckets of femurs and
skulls and tusks and
and you have those paleontologists who
are just like they can't even believe
what they're saying yeah that's because
a lot of those animals they say never
lived up there during the Ice Age
so when they see it
and they still think that I just say
well they sure as [ __ ] died here dude
[Laughter]
so it's changing their ideas of what
existed in that area yes sir wow and
what's the oldest bones you guys have
found we don't know
we've sampled maybe four or five of them
it costs 400 bucks a sample do a carbon
14 test on them
if I was to sample my entire collection
today it cost 100 million dollars
because we have a close to quarter
million fossils now
the whole place is crazy I mean it's
it's so hard to believe that this one
area has so many bones is there they
have no idea of like did these animals
fall into a muck pet was it
why are they there they don't know no
because there's so many of them and
we're talking bones we're not even
talking fossils right right because they
froze which is very very unusual right
the the
documentary you saw that dick mole
paleontologist what an unfortunate Name
by the way
dick mole
you know I see what you're saying there
I know you do yeah he uh is one of the
good ones you know he's he uh he came up
and spent a few days with us with the
filmmaker that made that film by the way
the filmmaker is a artist pure just
through and through and I met him when
he was working for National Geographic
and then he came to me and he says hey
I'd like to document make a documentary
about the Boneyard
so I gave him unfettered access for four
years just do what you got to do just
stay out of our way
don't make me worry about finding you
under a muck bench or a tree falling on
you just go do your thing
so he did and uh
the stuff that you're seeing there
and you saw in that video that you
watched the documentary
it's like nobody knows why any of that
stuff is there
is that the most unusual site that
they've ever discovered in terms of just
the sheer quantity of Bones yes
wow and you just found it by accident
yeah it just makes you think how many
more of those are out there well I know
one more really it's the next Creek down
yep so this area where you're extracting
these bones from how big is the actual
area where you're finding these five
acres that's it that's it
wow and I I get blamed well I have a
you've you're the
I gotta be honest with you on a little
thing here
when you first mentioned the Boneyard
Alaska
and talked about our site you I don't
know how you found it but you found it
you had uh
uh who would you have on here I think
it's Forest Gallant yeah it was Forrest
Galant
and I picked up 5 000 followers on my
Instagram account that day
and I said to myself
the only guy I ever talked to about this
site is Joe Rogan
ever
and I used you as a crutch
for three solid [ __ ] years
because I didn't want to talk to anybody
about this
but everybody's so interested in it I
said I'll talk to Joe Rogan that's it
I've had countless opportunities to talk
to
newscasters and and network reality TV
people that want to do blah blah blah
blah no I ain't gonna do it I'll talk to
Joe Rogan about it well thank you for
that no thank you for that my pleasure
but it's just so unusual at first I just
thought oh you probably found a couple
things on this place and then as um
going over your Instagram page I'm
seeing
all the stuff that you're pulling out of
there I'm like this doesn't even seem
real like how could this one area have
so many bones and so many tusks
like how many tusks do you have Mammoth
tusks we stopped Counting
not because
we can't count that high
it's just because what's the point
thousands
I have a friend that says I got ten
thousand dead woolly mammoth on my
ground wow in five acres yeah that's
insane I have any of these
paleontologists speculated on why this
one area would have so many dead animals
no
have they haven't told me
and so you you dated a few of them and
what were the dates from those few
they went
from as recent as three thousand years
ago to twenty two thousand years ago wow
and the reason this site is so
interesting to him is because it's from
all from one little area
so the context is there
and it spans What's called the
extinction event
Graham is yeah and Randall yeah the
younger driest impact Theory yeah and so
I'm kind of going along with them
because that would make sense why
they're all there well you got to
remember that the world the pleistocene
started what two and a half million
years ago and stopped about 11 800 years
ago yeah
so that whole area was Ice except for a
ice-free corridor between Siberia and
Alaska in the lower 48. they went right
through where we're at
so there was migration happening coming
through there
and these animals
lived there for tens of thousands of
years
the grazers
well wherever there's grazers there's
going to be carnivores
you have the short faced bear you got
the cave Lions you got we found all that
stuff you found short-faced Bears yes
sir really yep you got a short faced
bear head
yes what does that look like
huge how big is it
right back down
they stood when they stood up on their
hind legs they were 12 feet yeah we've
shown photos of uh these replicas
standing next to people yeah no it's
there's nuts yeah and and not only that
but you know you have a little mini
factoid for you you know it takes a
mammal 22 SEC 21 seconds to take a leak
did you know that no
check it out okay by the way I hope you
have your [ __ ] detector on I know
you got one and anytime you want to
throw it on you throw it on me I believe
you no
I'm just telling you so some of the
stuff sounds no no [ __ ] way there it
goes
20 seconds
empty their bladders in 20 about 20
seconds yeah the Golden Rule yeah all
mammals weighed more than 2.2 pounds
empty their full bladders in about 20
seconds
unless you've been drinking
I've gone 100 seconds before I bet you
have
it's kind of a contest yeah and uh
so anyways the uh
you got to remember also that a grizzly
bear can cover about 100 yards in eight
seconds
and they got some pretty powerful noses
on them so all these animals that
stopped to take a piss they get whacked
I that's my theory I don't think that's
a good theory it probably not
but other Theory though that I
discovered in Florida what
uh pelicans flying groups of prime
numbers
they do
it seems like that to me I pay attention
to [ __ ] like that Joe okay if you say
look there's a group eight pelicans
flying over there Uncle [ __ ] there's
one and then there's seven behind it
um
there there's 23 of them yeah you're
right prime number
interesting but I threw that out on my
Instagram one time to challenge people
go find a group of pelicans or pelicans
flying
in an odd number
and it was kind of hard for him
so
you ain't got Pelicans around here but
no
I'm not a fan
you ever see pelicans swallow seagulls
they just grab a seagull swallow it
whole they're ruthless [ __ ] oh
they are like people think of pelicans
oh they carry it's like a stork
they carry the baby those big birds
no that thing is to swallow giant things
that's why their mouth is so big I saw a
pelican last year Drew was with me and
it has a fish stuck sideways in its
gullet
he couldn't hack it out he couldn't get
it out and there wasn't another Pelican
around there to help it put his beak in
there and pull it out I mean this thing
was gagging on it
um don't even know what happened to him
they probably figured it out you'd think
yeah I mean they're evolutionarily
designed to swallow enormous things just
think they were they were goddamn
dinosaurs about 60 million years ago
yeah for sure
you know yeah
so it's a it's a wild place so this mass
extinction event Theory does explain why
there would be so many all in this one
area